ehrlicherweise am längst noch kein
mensch verdient
und schon garnicht kinder
[Musik]
lasst das temporär das größte kämpfe
gefürchtete in europa über 15.000 leute
leben her unter zum teil wirklich
katastrophalen bedingungen wie genau
deshalb sind die forderungen ja auch da
und vor allen dingen immer lauter dieses
camp rauch aufzulösen
let's dance corona
[Musik]
das muss noch mal sagen das ist
natürlich super ich meine die haben hier
so gut wie gar nicht zu und versuchen
sich gegenseitig zu helfen und mein
wasser ist hier wirklich knapp seife ist
er knapp aber sie versuchen zumindest
auch in bezug auf coroner das beste aus
dieser situation zu machen
[Musik]
model job in die kämpfe ein leading team
billig anzag liegt man irgendwie wieder
in seinem sauberen hotelbett nach einem
tag voller begegnung emotion frustration
abgründen hoffnungen enttäuschen
hoffnung und vielen vielen mehr
und ich kann nur sagen ich bin so
unfassbar dankbar für all die menschen
für die ngo s die immer noch hier sind
oder hier geblieben sind um den menschen
zu helfen
[Musik]
viele geflüchtete die mit dem boot über
also von der türkei nach griechenland
reisen die habe natürlich dabei und die
filmen auch die versuchung zu filmen die
gewalt die vor allem von der
griechischen küstenwache gegen sie
ausgeht
und ich finde es ganz wichtig zu sagen
ja es ist vor allem die griechische
küstenwache die hier die prospekte ruhig
wird und in einer in so viel gewalt da
das mir echt die worte fehlen
aber das ist auch europäische politik
das ist genau das was für die
europäische europäische union steht
[Musik]
akteur ist in die griechische
küstenwache
aber das ist in der europäischen union
das ist europäische abschottungspolitik
die hier passiert nichts passiert weil
keiner eingreift weil alle wissen dass
basis passiert also push back hat ja das
sagen uns ja auch die leute hier an land
dazu geführt dass weniger flüchtlinge
beziehungsweise geflüchtete menschen
auch com + co ohne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
falls sie sich übrigens wundern wozu das
da ist die zelte werden gerne mal
aufgeschlitzt man werden handys und
alles möglich heraus geklaut und das ist
der einzige schutz
[Musik]
was sollten sie veranlasst zu sagen ich
komme jetzt hierher ich will helfen
ich glaube dass natürlich froh dass
viele angst hatte abgezogen sind hier
einfach die versorgung
wir können gerade einmal in die
grundversorgung aufrecht reichen bei
weitem nicht so helfen wie wir es bei so
einer ansatzweise wollen jetzt ist es
wirklich gut macht auf den heißen stein
[Musik]
hier gab es heute nacht wurde eine
messerstecherei davon haben wir auch
gehört und jemand aus dem kongo soll
dabei gestorben seien und das ist
offensichtlich das video und das krasse
daran ist auch wie man hier sieht die
kinder sind ja auch von nichts geschützt
die sind möglicherweise dabei wenn es
passiert die gucken sich die videos an
das ist einfach wirklich schrecklich das
sollten kinder mich sehen und nicht
erleben
[Musik]
cantieni
absolutes minimum
[Musik]
ich bin fertig